only you can break your word and the day
you do you're nobody and that's what
made me at the age of 23 laying the
floor of a panama in jail being tortured
to death
where i bled for five years thereafter
because i was not gonna break my word no
we're drug dealers they just told you i
mean just like that we're drug dealers
we sell cocaine you would think i'd be
shocked and i should have been but
immediately my mindset was well you're
an accountant
you know that's what you were trained to
count money we are not defined by our
past there is hope there is faith
there is a god that forgives
you can you pay the consequences of our
choices but you can be different
so if you've seen the netflix special
cocaine cowboys my guest today is dr
jorge
valdez who from 1977 to 1980 was the
number one
cocaine salesman in the world 95 of
cocaine that was sold in miami was him
but he's got an interesting background
cuban immigrant hooks up with pablo
escobar
who was going to school he was going to
be somebody had a big gpa went to
university miami then he starts selling
drugs makes a million to 3 million a
year
in 1990 60 million dollars he lost
confiscated to get away from the life
then that leads to later on him becoming
a doctor
phd very very interesting story with
that being said said uh dr valdes thank
you so much for being a guest thank you
thank you it's my pleasure i gotta
compliment you on your suit man you look
amazing thank you very much
i've been following you for a while so i
saw your suits and i just want to dress
appropriately well i know you you took
it to a different level i mean i'm here
my assistant caroline said
there's a man jorge valdez who looks
very sharp in the office today i said
well that was that's what i was
expecting anyways
okay so before we go through this stuff
there's a lot of different things i want
to know but for the audience that
doesn't know your story why don't we
start from the beginning and we'll go
into some questions so here's the
interesting thing uh i came from cuba
at the age of 10 my parents were very
well-off
and uh but i had a mother it was very
religious
she wanted us to have nothing to do with
communism
and my father was a very wealthy man 40
years old he did not think that fidel
was going to impact
the rich you know that's how they didn't
think he was going to impact the rich
right he didn't think that it was
basically because you know fidel's first
agenda was i'm going to go after the
americans they have taken all this stuff
from the united states i mean from cuba
i never paid for it yeah so anyway so we
my mother said no we're leaving i'm
taking my kids out of the united states
i've been out of cuba and it was very
strange because you know i didn't know
any of this was going on right i'm just
a little kid i'm playing baseball in the
streets without the my passion
and uh but that date uh she wakes us up
at five o'clock in the morning well four
o'clock in the morning and she's like
get dressed we're leaving what year is
this 1966 october 11th
and patrick i'm there like where what
he said just put on
underwear
pack socks shoes shirt and belt
and that was strange because you know
we're going a lot of family trips and we
pack stuff and she's like no just what
you got on
so
you know we
back in that generation where you really
don't question your parents
at all so we headed out to the airport i
was in a trance and then of course at
the airport was the most traumatic i
said that my life shifted in like three
cataclysmic moments first one
was that day because as we're about to
our name be called my mother gets cold
and she finds out they're not going to
let her leave
and they said they made a mistake but
her father was a very very big figure in
cuba years back and she was very vocal
about you know her anti-communism stand
so she was or he he was no she was she
was also vocal when you say vocal what
does that mean in other sense that for
example one of the things that fidel did
is let's say your son all of a sudden
when he gets to be 12 and you're living
him in boca raton he's going to take
your kids from your house and you're
going to send them to california and
you're going to send some kids from
texas to your house why
because as we're going to school
they have what they call the pioneers
and the pioneers like the boy scouts but
it was their way of indoctrinating the
youth right into the communist ideal
so if i go home
and i tell my mom like i would what i
learned in school right there's no god
that's just
poor excuse for the poor
and my mother gives me hell well it
stays there but if i come home and i'm
living at your house and your wife tells
me that oh that's a bunch of bs and i go
back to school and tell the teacher
your wife will go to jail got it what a
way so he was the family so he was
breeding snitches and how to break up
families oh
i mean the first thing he did as far as
niches was every block had a snitch
every block had what they called a
committee the committee that reported
everything that went on just somebody
sat on her chair and rocked and and took
notes of cars coming in whatever was
going on
so that's what he did and my mother said
well before my children turn 12 i'm
taking him out of here
and you know my mom was born with a
silver spoon in her mouth her dad was
you know her dad at the age of 16 went
to the independence to fight with marcel
against spain and came back a general
and highly decorated until this point
the military base where he's from fidel
castro still named it after him that's
how much of a big figure he was like one
of our founding fathers here so
uh my mother of course she would curse
out the committee she didn't give a damn
about anyone she was i said my mother
was five foot man she had been five four
she'd be a terrorist
but um personality yeah unbelievable and
uh so she's like leaving well
she doesn't get to go
and my father said well if you're not
leaving i'm not gonna leave
so my father comes to me i'm ten my
brother's nine my sister's five
my mother comes grabbed my hand and said
george you take your brother's sister to
miami i'll see you one day
and that to me
like my whole world rocked because my
father like i'm not coming he eventually
he did get on the airplane as we were
boarding
and uh so we went from living in a house
that was one square block
each kid had a car you know very well to
do 211 i was living in a one bedroom
apartment in miami
well we had to write down what time
we're going to piss because everyone had
to go to school work
so all of a sudden when i got to miami
it was my first cataclysmic moment
all this stuff about god that my mother
has been telling me
mom you know what what they were
teaching me school was right there ain't
no god this is obs if we're coming from
cuba to be with god and this is god's
joke
you know
and uh
so i grew up till many years later a
diehard atheist
and uh and then the next day was
when this drive in me
awoke i i encountered my american dream
what was that
my cousin who had been there about a
year and a half earlier comes to visit
us
and he has
a candy apple red
white interior
gto
man patrick was like
this is it the day i get that i'm gonna
be somebody in america yeah
but you know my father was a man of
unbelievable principles you know my
father uh we had no food to eat
you know we we'd get two raw eggs and
the spotted milk that they gave us that
till today i take milk and i want to
vomit
and uh
and that's all we would have to
dinnertime and dinnertime with rice and
beans he's making 85 cents an hour
minimum wage doesn't speak english 40
years old three little kids
rent eighty dollars
i mean we're literally going through
hell well i find out that my friend has
lunch at school
and man i to me was a big discovery i
couldn't wait to get home and say hey
dad dad i found out my buddy
he has lunch he has a sandwich
to me a sandwich is like now having a
three pound lobster and he's like you
know you know the old uh generation
didn't speak much you know kids were
meant to be seen not to be heard
so he just knocks his head
and he's like uh i said he tells me he
gets footsteps
i said dad do you know about footsteps
and he's like
lost his head he said well why don't we
get food stamps dad
he's like some because that's for poor
people
and i looked at him patrick and he was
like holy crap
we're not even poor yet
you mean we still gotta climb our way
out of wherever that's called to get to
poverty
i said dad we're not poor
he pointed a finger in my chest and said
no son we don't have any money
people that take money from the
government are poor in a state poor you
figure out how to get up early and help
feed your family i was 10 years old i
weighed probably 90 pounds unbelievable
and at 5 30 in the morning i've been
getting up ever since that day and i'm
65 today
to help feed my family to to uh deliver
newspaper i was so skinny i couldn't
even ride my bike the papers would flip
me over i had to walk until i got rid of
enough newspapers and we did that but
tremendous principle you know my father
was
there was one thing that he taught me
it still resonates with me today at 65
and i and i've been and you know told to
my children over and over again
and to me my brother used to look at
each other he goes man there goes a damn
broken record he would come up to us i
don't know when i said son
in life you have no control whether
you're dead or alive
no control whether you're sick or
healthy
no control whether you're rich or poor
and i'm like no i can figure that
one out yeah he said the only thing you
have absolute control son is your word
only
your word word only you can break your
word
and the day you do you're nobody
and that's what made me at the age of 23
laying the floor of panama in jail being
tortured to death
where i bled for five years thereafter
because i was not gonna break my word
and uh but i had clear lines you know
uh i didn't do by the time i joined
that group that went on to become the
medellin cartel because here's the
interesting there was no managing cartel
okay so i've seen a lot of the
interviews uh jorge shaw finally came
out and said the same thing there's a
group of families
that control the drug trade in colombia
and that group the americans said hey
if we
bundle them up and call it the million
cartel we have one enemy and who seems
to be the head pablo but the truth of
the matter is neither pablo was the
wealthiest neither apollo was the
richest there were people so much more
powerful and wealthier that no one's
ever known their name come on and see
and here's what's interesting about
when they came to me about cocaine
cowboy net uh the producers i turned
them down three times
three times
for numerous reasons but mainly two two
main reasons that i always had
and that is that somebody sits there and
watches this show
and said hey it's glamorous it was
exciting but because you guys have
buried a child or worse yet some kid
drops out of school and says i'm gonna
become like son willie
and become a drug dealer and become rich
it's gonna happen it's never gonna
happen
so i was always hesitant of that until
the last time when i told them you tell
the bad with the good and i'll do it
because the interesting thing is
no one see every story that you hear
narcos all of them what do they start
with pablo escobar
well patrick that's a whole big world of
enormous drug trafficking before paul
escobar even surfaced out of poverty
so the number you hear about is the fact
that pablo at his peak was worth 20
billion i don't think so by no means by
no means by no means so who would you
say was bigger than pablo well there was
numerous ones there was a guy named that
we nicknamed negro who pablo killed and
uh he was much much wealthier than him
uh gotcha was much wealthier than pablo
the thing with pablo was
he was not the wealthiest
or the most powerful he was the most
ruthless
if pablo killed you he would kill all
your males in your family
and he had no respect
for human life
no respect for human life zero respect
human life meant nothing to him
but and that's what ruined the the
business and because
the group that i got enlisted to it was
only four and me five
it was five of us i controlled 95 of all
the cocaine that came to the u.s
that group was very different than all
this group see i tell this to people
real simple
i'm going to give you the script for
pablo escobar for gotcha sal
willie
chapel the same script
poor kid
goes out of school
joins a life of crime
becomes powerful
lives a lavish lifestyle kills people go
to jail or die that's the same script
put whatever name you want on it
put the same name they're all the same
identical script that's not my story
and that's not the story that i ever
wanted to tell
see yeah i was poor because i came to
united states and we lost everything but
i was the youngest employee in the
federal shirt bank at the age of 17.
you know i was an honor student i went
to school full time
and i worked at the federal serb bank
full time i went to school at the
university of miami full-time own
scholarship
and i had i never done drugs
didn't drink all the alcohol by the age
of 20 that i drank fit in the teacup
that size still today no i i love my
wine today okay so you know i do yes
she's validating that exactly she's
validating that
but
you know i i can tell you what i did for
four years every day of my life i got up
at 5 30 in the morning i was at the bank
at 6 30 i worked at 3 30. i got home at
four my mother had dinner i leave the
house at 4 30 4 45 i have my first class
you know
miami 5 30. i leave at 10 30. i go home
and i study till 2 30. i did that every
day for four years
so your mom eventually came to miami
yeah my mom eventually joined us about
uh seven months later seven months yeah
so you were 11 years old when she came
to me
right before i turned 11 years old i was
still 10 so so so you're now uh you're
going to school you're an honor student
you're very uh systematic you have
discipline mom and dad have taught you
strong values
mindset of you're not poor mindset of
standing up for yourself don't be a weak
you're strong respectful all of these
things your parents have taught you so
your trajectory at this point is what
who is
jorge valdez going to end up being at
this point
i had a clear vision i would i would
graduate from miami at 20
i take a couple years to work save
enough money i go to law school at 22
23. i graduate from law school at 25 and
i'm going to be a millionaire at 30
because if i'm not a millionaire i'm a
nobody that's how you're seeing and that
was my whole world and nothing would
deviate from that i had a little
girlfriend that i would see very very
seldom and if we ever went ever we
hardly even went to party went to a
party and i smelled pot now remember the
70s which is like probably like alcohol
now yeah i i don't know i gotta leave
i'm a federal employee
i can't you know are you crazy
i got this view i didn't have a traffic
ticket i didn't have anything in my life
and uh
and that was the whole thing
and uh and then
so i'm gonna be a lawyer by 30
millionaires this is what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna be a lawyer by 25 million or
by 30 is what i'm going to be doing
because if i'm not that i'm nobody
okay so your identity sink or swim
that's it i'm not playing small i'm
gonna go do something big and this is a
million 30 years old in what 70s like
early early 80s 76 26 okay yeah so so
okay so now what happens when you get
introduced to this life so i at 76 my
accounting professor
uh he had left from michigan it was a
partner president waterhouse came to
miami and this speaks spanish so he's
like hey george
if you come work for me and do my
spanish clients i'll give you secretary
office
everything to start your business and to
me that was like heaven opening up
because i wanted to be on my own i mean
i thought i had a heck of a future at
the federal reserve bank
me and the vice president of the federal
reserve bank office were the only two
that they paid tuition to go to
university of miami everybody else had
to go to state college
so
when he told me that my mother
my father very conservative you're crazy
stay with the bank you have a hell of a
future my mother you'll never be nobody
working for somebody
so you know my mother was everything in
our house like most uh hispanic mothers
and uh and i resigned and i went to work
for him and the first client that he
gave me was a little grocery store in
miami like a little strip uh joint and
not a not a strip club strip joint it's
just slightly different no a
little different you don't like those
shopping centers in miami right together
i mean like i don't know 10 feet what 15
feet wide 40 feet uh deep
and uh it was a little grocery store
and i go there monday i'm supposed to go
every monday
in the morning a couple hours and pay me
a thousand dollars right there i'm gonna
be rich thousand dollars i mean i'm
making minimum wage is 85.95 i'm making
350 working for the bank i'm a big shot
you know
a thousand dollars for three hours i'm
mad so i go there and they have a little
office in the back
and i go and i see this paper sack
and he had like a hundred somewhat
thousand dollars
and i'm like
wow i look around you know where these
rules should still produce that i
thought well maybe they haven't made the
boxes in a year i don't know no clue
zero clue what's going on
do my accounting
go to the bank deposit the hundred
thousand dollars boom show up next week
seventy five thousand
and i'm like
no there's gotta be something wrong
so the only thing i could think of
there's a shelf and i never forget it
had a a can of campbell's soup
and it was dusty it's been sitting there
for a long time so i'm gonna go and i'm
gonna put a v on top of that can i want
to see if this can't sell because i'm
coming back next week and
now i'm like yeah
what a thing to do but think about this
now suspicious that something's going on
the least of them all if they gave me a
hundred choices i would have showed
cocaine as the hundredth of the choices
got it oh what was going on remember now
how were they as people just regular
people and yeah just regular yeah
regular colombian uh pretty wild you
know
everyone thought he got mad at the wife
so the wife gets out and gets a bigger
piece of ham and throws it at him at the
store and he takes out his gun shoots
the ham and puts it back in the counter
i'm like oh these people a little
different than i am
so you're 20 21 at this time i'm 20.
okay got it i'm 20. it's 1976. i just
left the bank
and uh
so
do my accounting go back
and the next week when i come there's
another hundred times i'm like no i need
explanation and i never forget i called
him in there and said bro let me give
you a little accounting lesson
you see that can of campbell's soup
that's still there because i put a v on
it and
he hasn't got nowhere to have the v
well
if that can is a dollar and you sell it
tomorrow for three dollars
you have generated three dollars worth
of income and two dollars worth of
profit
so here's the problem i've deposited
close to three hundred thousand dollars
and yet the receipts for all you bought
don't add up to 1500 bucks
what gives
you think that they would like come up
with some
they looked at me and they're like oh
yeah this is nothing no we're drug
dealers they just told you i mean just
like that we're drug dealers
we sell cocaine now let me go back at
least they're honest about it yeah in
the 70s
in the 70s cocaine does not have the
stigma that cocaine has and should have
today right in the 70s it was for the
rich and famous the hollywood
celebrities i mean you could buy a
gorgeous house in miami four bedroom for
40 grand and a kilo cocaine was 60 to
70.
so who had this right
so
they're like
yeah we're drug dealers and by the way
we've been meaning to ask you we know
you work for the government uh
do you know how to open foreign bank
accounts
and i'm like yeah i happen to know
and they're like how much and i just
threw a number for the heck of just
getting stop this conversation list go
on move over
and uh i said ten thousand dollars and
it was fifteen hundred bucks about the
cost
and they're like uh can you open three
now immediately i added up three i'm
gonna make about eight grand profit you
know three of them and twenty four
thousand
three bucks an hour at the bank think
about making about a thousand dollars a
month you know like this is 25 years
worth of labor
and they're like uh i'm like sure and i
did and i began to open
four mega and so this is what's really
interesting i tell people i had drawn a
line that i wouldn't cross
for nothing
but all of a sudden
the fact that he was just people that
couldn't hardly read and write and
they're making ungodly amounts of money
and here i am busting my ass
working honestly going to school no
sleep
and i'm barely getting by
and it's like
so we come up with excuses right i'm
going to do it one time
okay i'll open this company and that
that gives me the money
to go to law school
we we're great at justifying it right i
tell people listen nobody drinks a
gallon of vodka the first time he's
gonna die
you know no one shoots at ounce of
heroin you start with a little and then
you come up with a good excuse because
that's how we are we're wired to justify
all of our actions
and immediately the first way i just
when he told me there were cocaine
dealers you would think i'd be shocked
and i should have been but immediately
my mindset was well you're an accountant
you know that's what you would drink to
count money there's no money laundering
laws you're doing nothing wrong just a
customer just immediately just another
club what they do that's their problem
they go to jail that's their problem
yeah um hey i'm providing a service that
i paid all those years to work for yeah
and uh
and it did
and i started to open foreign bank
accounts and i started what was
considered by the government the
original web of the most sophisticated
money laundering because immediately i
started to become friends with ministers
of finance in countries all over the
world
i'm barely i'm not even 21 yet
i have braces i look like a nerd if you
look up nerdy in the dictionary bang
that was my picture that's how it looked
i mean it like it was like
i look back i mean there's a picture i
have a picture when i started with a
cartel with a
yellow jersey from my high school
and uh
i'm like
so
i start making this money for them and
shortly thereafter and these things
escalate
so this is like towards the end of 1976
77 coming on
and
and it begins to escalate really really
fast
so
with a month within a couple months they
come
and they tell me we want you to meet our
boss
he has a business proposition for you
and i'm like okay so i meet him and this
is the guy that was
the original
head of what would become the medium
cartel this is the guy from who a lot of
oldest people
came from
and uh and he's like hey we are we're
interested in starting a banana import
business
and uh we want to buy a ship
and we want to start bringing bananas
and we want to you know i mean
and here's the interesting thing
he and his partners they were business
people they had tons of business they
wore a suit they talked like you and i
talked this is how we would think that
you see pablo and all his sicario that
no this is what i mean he owned the
largest construction company in colombia
he owned the largest coal mine the
largest emerald mine airlines so
i'm thinking that he's proposing a
legitimate business i mean he's like
well we want you to be the president
and i'm like sure i said look
i want equal partnership
or and seven thousand dollars a month
come on 7000 that was like a fortune
they look at me and they're like no
problem i'm like shoot i should have
asked for more
and we flew out to california and we
bought a big old landing ship you know
and uh and those were those big cargo
ships where they would go up to the
shore the military drop a hatch and they
offload equipment and stuff like that
little did i ever imagine what the real
intention was with the banana company
and it shows how it wasn't bananas
so
we buy this ship and i'm in california
and we got to refurbish it to uh do
refrigerate it
and uh while i'm out there the guy
that's doing the refrigeration for me
starts harassing me it's like hey man i
know that's a cocaine boat
and i'm like dude you're wrong
i said look you think i'm stupid enough
that if this is going to do something
illegal i would have my name on it i was
that stupid because i had no idea
and you're like no speculation you're
not zero okay because they didn't talk
like you would think
the stigma they're like these are
business people we talked about
feasibility study we did visibility
study with the financial statements we
did all this stuff that you would expect
i mean try to tell us any one of those
guns today let's do a feasibility said
look at like what the hell is that yeah
you know
how much money here's a bunch of cash
so
anyway uh
so i come back to miami and i tell the
guy
that started me with the partners right
the guy that was this guy that was
always hanging at the grocery store
which was the boss of the two owners of
the grocery store
and uh i said hey
you won't believe this man these people
keep thinking that
that this boat is for cocaine and i keep
telling him no he's like man you know
you can make a lot of money if you find
a good buyer out there and i'm like dude
i don't want nothing to do i say be
stupid if you guys to get me involved in
that when i'm handling all your money
now i'm depositing half a million
dollars a month 1976. it's a lot of cash
and uh checked at it till one day i bit
he's like hey
take three kilos out there you have to
do nothing we'll send it out there
send it to your guys and see what
happened well one thing led to the other
and this is where i tell my second
cataclysmic moment i go to a party now
my circle of influence has changed right
no longer am i all that dead beat
buddies you know i tell my son my
generation
people say oh wow incredible you worked
full time i went to school full time so
did all my friends
that was our generation you know we all
wanted to get ahead we all had families
you know because back then you married
early and we all have responsibilities
so i go to a party now now those are not
my friends anymore right
now
i started in the in the circle of their
friends
the rich
the famous the musicians the boxing
promoters big big names back in the 70s
and i go to a party and i see a a judge
strung out on cocaine
a judge a judge that gave people
hundreds of years for cocaine offense
and i looked at him and i'm like man
there's no god and there's there are no
morals in this country
because
this group that started what would
become the main cartel nobody did drugs
they're like hey
this is for
the idiots to make us rich
so i'm like
at least or not and they're like we want
you to handle all operations in the
united states when i said no when i said
yes i would right uh but here's the deal
i said i gotta be equal partners
and you got to put up my part because i
ain't got no money
needless to say i said that sort of like
just leave me alone you know because
here's this powerful people having a 21
year old kid telling them he wants to be
equal partner and they got to finance
him
and he has no idea i don't even know
what cocaine looks like never seen in my
life
and uh and they're like let's think
about it i'm like good so i'm headed
back the next morning back to california
and when the chauffeur comes to bring me
up he says uh the manuel wants to see
you
so i'm like okay maybe we forgot to talk
something about can we talk literally
like you would with anybody that worked
for you in another city running some
operation
and uh
and there was his other partners
and uh man and he was stoic looking
i mean it's like and i'm like oh man we
didn't forget to die this is i'm dead
i was stupid what the hell you know i
insulted the hell out of these people
and they're gonna let me know really
quick what they think about so they look
at me and like we discussed it and not
and we agree we'll let you handle all
our operations in the u.s now what the
hell does that mean
i don't know what cocaine looks like
how did i bring it in
who am i going to sell it to
well i knew those guys in california
what am i going to do with the money how
am i going to get it to california how
am i going to get the money to back to
colombia
all of that for a kid that
never broke the law in his life now no
more just handling money as an
accountant that i'm doing to me i'm
going to handle this big large operation
and think about it
if you sold cocaine cowboy in netflix
you see there was a big operation in
miami called operation video canary
operation video canary they arrested
every drug dealer that there was in
miami right
they were all selling graham sounds like
sean wooly who literally like the
producers that i handed him or the
prosecutor said i handed him the keys to
the kingdom they were selling rams at a
disco
for years
my name never came up and i was bringing
in 800 kilos for two years
800 a month
i was making a million to three million
dollars a month
we were doing anywhere between 50 and 80
million dollars a month almost a billion
a year
in 1977 78 money
it's a lot of
a lot of money back then what is life
like at that time
well needless to say
you know it's like like the young
athletes that signed the big country
they broke all their lives i was the
same no different right but
i invested a lot but
i bought jets mansions rolls royces uh i
had every known car you can imagine and
i dated some of the most beautiful women
in america and i said and i and i wrote
a blog that i said i'm 22 years old i
make a million dollars a month
i have mansions jets helicopters
million dollar car and i want to die
and i want to die and saying that's the
message that i wanted to get across the
lobby and i think they did a really good
job in cocaine cowboys because
the thing about it is see patrick i
thought that
once i reached my american dream
which is not what the american dream is
the american dream is
the world war ii generation that worked
their butts off to have a job in a
decent retirement one house
they had marriage problem but divorce
was not an option you know they hated
the war like all of us
serving was an honor they'd rather be an
hour earlier than a minute late that's
the american dream our american dream is
just a false it's the fact that you you
have this hunger within you and society
is quick to tell you
listen
when you do this you're gonna be happy
when you date this gorgeous model look
at them tv well listen i woke up next to
them they don't look the same in the
magazine as they do when they wake up
out of bed
you're supposed to be happy everybody's
telling you you're god
you know you did a video that i liked a
lot when you talk about how people are
constantly wanting people to like them
you know
and it's interesting that we live in a
world that that video you didn't get as
many views as some of the other
mafia videos when that video had
unbelievable message
to me
it did because it's so true right we're
constantly wanting people to praise us
we want why because we're miserable
and we need affirmation
see and instead of people saying to me
listen george you're the scum of the
earth
no it didn't matter what i did you're
you're so you know
you're the best to hang out with you're
this you're that so at that time when
you're making a million to three million
a month and you guys are doing a bill a
year
uh what is your mom and dad think you're
doing so see that's the thing my mom did
not have no idea what i was doing did
they ever come to your mansion did they
get on the jets no they oh yeah but they
thought that i was a legitimate
businessman because we had we had cattle
farms we had businesses that they could
see we had construction companies i took
my flight to columbia a couple times to
see uh the house that i bought which was
a bigger development that we have built
so they saw that and this is the this is
where the problem comes with sal and
willie
so
my dad is best friends with them with
his father
forever since cuba
uh every day after dinner till they all
died they would visit each other's house
for coffee
[Music]
to me they were like my parents loved
them to death well
so salsa i lost track what's up because
they dropped out of high school i kept
on going to college
and every time my dad went to his
parents house he was like hey tell
george to give me a chance to georgia
because of course my dad being a typical
hispanic he's bragging about his son how
his son is doing so well how his son is
driving our you know all of this stuff
not knowing really what his son was
doing
so
i was afraid they were gonna tell my dad
when i give him a meeting
you know i was afraid that hey
you know let me talk to him because
sooner or later he's going to spill it
and then you know my parents it would
destroy my parents which eventually did
and it's the greatest regret of the many
regrets that i have
you know people tell you tell me is like
don't you miss that life
well you have a jet i don't show
something that's mine
of course you miss it you miss the thing
i don't miss it tell me hey do you miss
having a 747 i never had one so i don't
mean you missed the thing that you had
but the thing is that none of that gave
me the joy that i have today
because today my joy is not in that
thing my joy is in me
and who i am and who created me
so
in that in that time when you're doing
the by the way very uh insightful and i
love the fact that you're you're sharing
that with the audience because sometimes
messages can come across as being
glorified and young people look up to us
i'd love to have that kind of accolades
the cars all this stuff and i don't care
if i need to live the fast life but but
going back to during that time while
you're doing
business with all these different types
of folks who are you negotiating with
who are you dealing with political
people celebrities billionaires uh you
know uh other are you doing dealings
with pablo are you doing dealings who
are you who are you dealing with at that
time pablo is not even in the picture
yet okay pablo doesn't even surface
until 1980 81 i'm in jail when he
services
uh so i'm dealing with literally
we paid for the presidential campaign of
the president of costa rica
a million dollars i'm dealing with uh
somosa in nicaragua uh we're spending
half a million to a million a month in
bribery right here in the us
two things we couldn't bribe
an appellate judge
d.a or fbi agent you couldn't could not
why not because they just won't take it
and it wasn't much that we would ask him
now i'm not saying that there's not some
that will shake it but i'm telling you
as a whole and it's not like i'm going
to go to the d.a agent and so how does
bribery work corruption work real simple
everybody knows somebody right and your
circle becomes very very big
so if i know you know that federal judge
right like one that we tried to get to
who was an appellate judge
to rule on my behalf when i had all the
rights to win i had the best lawyers in
the world i had a millionaire with the
lawyers
so i said hey
all i want is a fair verdict i'll pay a
million bucks
so it's not like a stranger copy to
patrick the federal judge is the guy
that patrick hangs out with all the time
so
everybody has somebody so at the state
level politicians
politicians it didn't matter who it was
we had no need to buy to buy the
president united states back then but i
guarantee if we needed to we could have
because
think about a million dollars a month in
1977.78
you're talking about what eight nine ten
million dollars now yeah you know
uh power corrupt and absolute power
corrupts absolutely sure sure and when
you you can get to people and basically
all we needed from people what was gold
for us
was information
that's what was important we were not
looking at hey he's in jail get him out
that's that was easy you know that at
that time you can do that very very
cheap are you also living the uh life
where you're hurting people you are you
guys having to
collect are you also living the life
where you have to harm is there you know
murders taking place or no that wasn't
your world not at all
i'll give you two examples one example
were
it was a big test for me
my godfather the guy that started this
group where pablo and all of them come
from he's 93 years old today
still around still around for him never
never had a bodyguard
even doing the worst killings in
colombia and he was on the list to be
extradited twice right
never had a bodyguard
one time i asked permission to knock
somebody off
and i'm not a killer you know i had grew
up i was a nerd you know i was not i
didn't grow up on the streets as a
street kid
but you wake up every day and they tell
you hey uh patrick
says you put a concept in your life and
patrick's gonna put a contract in your
life and i know that i can wipe out
patrick in two seconds
right
so i asked him i said manuel here's the
deal
this guy
keeps threatening me and he's out there
asking people
telling people he's going to kill me and
at any given moment any human being can
be killed right
i want to get rid of him
and this was his response
no
he says
a million dollars we bring back and make
any day of the week a life we can't
bring back
i'm like but the life you won't get to
bring back is mine
and he's like you do what is right
before god and you'll be okay
and this is one of the founding members
of the cartel yeah
this is the guy that said to me if you
have to carry a gun to deal with someone
you have no business dealing with that
person
so here was one test he put me at the
beginning at the very beginning he tells
me one day he says
hey there's this guy oscar
that owes me ninety thousand dollars i
want you to go collect it
so you know i get a couple guys we're
gonna go collect the ninety thousand
dollars
i
never never asked me that we never had
to do that
everybody we dealt with we've known for
ages you know we're doing all this we're
doing millions of dollars on a handshake
so
i go see the guy
he opens the door
and ushers me and doesn't i call him up
hey i need to see come to my house that
was a little weird so i go to his house
and he said look i got ripped off and
look it takes me to the refrigerator his
wife was about to give birth had nothing
in the refrigerator no milk nothing he
says
just tell manuel that the minute i
my wife gives birth and we find an
apartment
i'll give you the deed to the house
i got ripped off but i want to pay my
dad
so i looked at the guy and i told the
guy that went with me go to the car and
bring me you know i called um which was
ten thousand dollars so he comes back
and i give it to him i said listen man
forget about the debt the day you can
pay us pay us but in the meantime here
just go buy stuff for your baby and your
wife and get yourself settled and you'll
never hear from us again
i called my godfather and he like did
you collect
i said well i got bad news for you i
said not only did i not collect but you
owe me 10 000.
and he's like so i tell the story this
was his words that's exactly what i
wanted to see you do
total different people
than the scum that came
after and it's very very sad because i
say i say to people what's one of the
reasons why pablo escobar got killed
well real simple because of pride and
ego
i mean do you think that he needs to
kill this one guy a negative who's a
really decent guy because the guy at a
christmas party said hey pablo's got all
the fame but i got all the money
and pablo kills him
he hasn't
assassinated the guy doesn't die
and then he's at the clinic and this
guy's got a lot of power and pablo walks
in with all his goons and kills him
himself in the clinic
so
very different from the world but all of
this
is beginning to surface while i go to
prison see in 1978
so
when i gave silent willie a chance
and what it was basically what it was is
when i meet with them to tell them
listen stop talking to my father and i'm
like he's like come on man give me a
chance i said well okay how much you
want to buy coke how much do you have to
buy
and he's like uh 20 000
and i started laughing i wanna pee my
pants
twenty thousand dollars dude think i saw
grams
sixty thousand dollars is a kilo man and
nobody said and nobody's selling one
kilo
so i'm like all right
let me see if i can ever give you a
chance i'll try to work out but right
now we're committed and and even the
cartel even this group right they didn't
want us to sell much in miami because
they felt that listen don't poop where
you eat our market is california new
york that's where all the fame and all
the glory and all the celebrities you
know that were our customers just think
about any famous singer in the 1975 76
77 78 they bought from us
so
i said let me get a chance well two
months later i had just bought a brand
new uh
i think that that was a 450 sl mercedes
convertible in german i was going to
pick it up
and
in every load one of the things that we
did see
if i tell you
like one of the things that i i wrote is
called the narcomaster journal and
basically
the way i built that empire is no
different than the principle i used to
get my phd which is the hardest academic
achievement in america and no different
than building a multi-million dollar
national international company as a
twice convicted drug dealer same thing
but one of them to me was this win-win
i felt that if i approached the world
with a win-win
then
nobody beat my enemy so for example and
this took on later on became more
important
so i'm bringing in
800 kilos
you're pablo you're gotcha
you're frank
kiki whoever and you say
because it's a small world right
yeah hey man
george and manuel they're bringing loads
left and right
you know what's going to happen sooner
or later they're going to knock me off
or tell on me
like i'll just review on your show for
the first time in history as pablo
escobar was doing with the dea for years
on people
under a presumed name
so
meaning meaning pablo was cooperating
the entire time with the d.a yeah but
you know he wasn't doing it to cooperate
because he believed in law enforcement
he was like hey was decent wait for me
to get real pat
i just found out that patrick is
bringing in the load on such and such
day
so he gave him a name and with that name
thinking that maybe he'll get credit one
day for it right or or they'll come to
his aid well
good luck
so but if i say all of a sudden okay
manuel
let's divide the load in half 400 kilos
is us
and then let's take among three of the
biggest guys then divide the other 400
kilos 150 under 500.
then what happens instead of being
jealous and wanting to knock me off what
are they doing they're rooting me on
because i'm bringing in their stuff
everybody's got their own routes that's
why there was no cartel
every group had their own
pilots their own bankers their own
buyers their own distributors in the u.s
they had their own assassins
so it was not like there was this one
harmonious group right
so
with that said
manual
in this one specific load we're supposed
to deliver 30 kilos to this one guy and
when my when my guy that that would do
the distribution
calls comes to find out we had codes
so when i called you you i knew you had
to talk to me in a certain way but the
idiot the agent where he was like well
how many and who sent it
so my guy's like hey i'm just looking to
rent an apartment hung up back then you
know there was no way to trace those
brick phones
so
uh lo and behold i have 30 kilos left
now i'm leaving for europe the next day
so i'm like let me see what
sal can do so i called him and i said
you want a break he's like yeah yeah i
said all right i got 30 kilos and you
have a month because i called the guy in
columbus and look you almost got us
busted so here's the deal i charged them
7 000 for the transportation so i said
what the best i'm going to do with you
30 kilos i'm going to take my 7 000
out of your cocaine at wholesale when
she was paying 18 so i'm gonna take you
know three kilos to pay for your freight
and then the rest i'm gonna dump dumping
in a dumpster you come here i'll tell
you where it is go get it say y'all no
please please don't do that you ruin me
i said so here's the best i'm gonna do
i'll buy him at what you pay for in
columbia
18 and i'll pay you when i come back
well
it only called me three i was charging
seven but it only called me three so now
i had sixty thousand dollar cocaine for
twenty one thousand dollars so i called
sal
and uh and he's like we can't handle
that and his partner willie i don't know
if you saw serious everybody keeps
calling them dumb
but he's like oh i can do it i can do it
and a month later when i come back they
had the money
so they did and they start
and every every load they start bringing
in okay
so at the end of 1978
sao comes to me and says hey
there's this captain in the bolivian air
force
that's working with the believing
government and they want to deal with
you directly
so i go meet with him
and he's like
i can give you cocaine at wholesale in
bolivia which we're paying 18 000
because at this time colombia is not
producing any cocaine
all the cocaine is coming in paste
colombia is crystallizing it right it's
all coming in pace or already
crystallized from bolivia peru
he said i can hear you at ten thousand
and for each kilo you buy i'll give you
one on credit
so at this time colombia is not the
producer there
you said it's coming coming in from
bolivia and peru
so this is what
78 77 78 79
so
i don't know when columbia started
producing probably in 1980
so which is how pablo got started right
pablo would just go out there he was
sent by one of the
the bosses hey go bring 40 kilos or 30
kilos and that's how ancient that was
they would drive it you know across the
borders into colombia so and he was one
thing he was he was sharp and he was a
risk taker and a hustler so it didn't
take him long to get power and was he a
tough guy was he a tough guy even pre
him uh going into a cocaine or see i
never i never dealt with him until i've
taken out a prison afterwards so i never
had any relationship uh and all our
conversations were by phone because this
time i can't leave the united states
when i got released and and he of course
can come to the united states so
but you know all the stories that i hear
from people that were real real close to
him and i know him yeah he was uh he was
a tough kid he was a street hustler i
mean he grew up on the streets stealing
uh tombstones and reselling them you
know and it's sad because his mother was
a school teacher that everybody loved
but you know it is very interesting
because
how can we not have
drug cartels
in essence united states
multinational create all the cartels
why because i'll tell you one specific
incident and like that multiply them all
over latin america so we went to
colombia now when we're going full blast
and uh and and later on and we said okay
so here's the deal you're growing
bananas yeah uh how much to pay you an
acre let's say ten dollars
and we don't have enough u.s uh you know
unified united states banana corporation
all of those companies that come and
they buy and when they don't need no
more they tell us to stick it and we
don't even have rules to take it to
medellin in the city yeah so we're
barely living we're dying you know our
our lifespan is not very much so here
comes the big bad drug dealers right and
we say hey patrick 10 no we're gonna pay
a hundred and we're gonna build you
roads because we don't give a demo about
your bananas we'll build your roads so
that you can take some of the bananas
back to the city and we'll build your
hospital and we'll build your schools
and you're gonna grow cocaine
so what are they going to do who is the
immoral person here
you know and that's what and that's what
happens in all latin america
we're not going to end up any war on
drugs that's the biggest joke in the
world
war on drugs cocaine seventy percent uh
over those problems in the world and
it's all the money on the war on drugs
you want war on drugs you go out to
pharma and they're 72 of all overdoses
in america
so
we don't want to stop it because it's a
big thing and i'm not saying this in a
negative way to the many agents like the
ones you had in your show that are
honest people that are really out there
risking their lives to try to make this
a better world for everybody i'm not
saying that i'm talking about at the big
big level i'm talking about those that
pull all the strings and do all that
they do and you know and and the crusher
that was huge huge
anyway
so
with that said uh you know they come in
there and and they start growing the
banana so he so i meet with the captain
and he makes this offer i go back to
manuel now and he's like no we don't i
don't want you involved in any of that
i'm like why not
and he's like
because those people are animals think
about a columbian telling those people
further down south he said look my
nephew went out there to make a deal and
after i paid a lot of money to send them
to me cut in four pieces in a box wow
he said they don't play games over there
and he says and why do you want to go
over there
um you know how we're bringing in the
cocaine miami international airport two
customs
that simple 800 kilos every month like
clockwork who are you paying off customs
agent two of them what are you paying
everybody we're paying him we started
paying him two thousand dollars and when
i i did the last payment in april 79
before i went off on my trip i paid him
seven thousand dollars
five and a half million dollars i paid
him these guys
were genius there were two brothers
and they
lived in the crappiest little house in
miami
drove the crappiest car that you ever
seen
to the last payment that we ever made
no one ever known half million yeah i
mean they made they made with us
i mean
think about it 800 we're paying anyway
we started paying three
three
thousand dollars a kilo
three million dollars
a month
for two years and it went from three to
six million
so they made i don't know 60 70 million
dollars just the two brothers in 77 and
78 what happened to them i don't know
because i went up to prison and after
that never heard them my god my they
disappear
so
i'm the only one that knew them
right and and and and someone that was
close to me but when they went to try to
make contact we had a number right we go
would happen every third thursday of the
month we would put an airplane we would
take
this big diesel caterpillar engine
right hollow them out put a 55-gallon
drum that would hold 115 kilos
and and load that up with with our
grease and then we'll bring it to miami
they would call me
i would call them on wednesday i would
give them a code
and on thursday morning
they knew
when i gave them that code they knew
where i had left
that wednesday night at u-haul
and that thursday morning
they would give me another call and i
would pick up the u-haul with the uh
empty hollowed-out engines that look
like they have been sent to columbia to
be rebuilt caterpillar and that's how we
did it for you i didn't come through the
bahamas and all that crap
don't tell when you're going back and
forth are you feared are you respected
are you admired how how do other people
look at you oh tremendous admiration
admiration and tremendous respect not
fear no because there was no need to
fear anybody i mean they knew that i had
this enormous
organization behind me but
why is there to fear we're not no one's
dying nobody's dying nobody's getting
killed literally no one's getting killed
when is people start dying think about
it we will start down with the cocaine
cowboys with that
shooting at the liquor store in miami in
de lemon 8182 when the mario boatlift
came to the united states and some of
those guyman good guys came but fidel
emptied out the scum of the year 25 125
000 yeah i mean think about it
this
every every criminal organization in the
world has been in federal prison right
everyone
the only one ever in history to take
over two united states penitentiary
lewisburg and atlanta were the cubans
from the marielle now how they were in
lockdown since the first day they
entered that penitentiary
i know guards that would tell me that
they would walk by those guys and they
would take chop a finger and throw it at
them
i mean and you know what's funny they
were highly literate they could read and
write because in cuba
even if you're in prisons and you're 9
years old you're going to learn how to
read and write and do math
but they were like
animals
and they came and they took over they
started working that's when things
started to really uh change
what's your opinion on jimmy carter at
that time because it's uh there's a if
you have any because it's a link to that
yeah you know what i don't have any
opinion about no no dealings or anything
look we are dealing with the cia okay i
mean
even before our cocaine there's another
world that nobody stepped into which is
the cubans that went to cuba and the
real pigs that were the big pot
smugglers in miami you know but nobody
ever messed with that right because
again
there's no violence
it's it's it's a good old boy business
and uh nobody's getting killed nobody's
cheating anybody you know you're doing
everything on a handshake and
everybody's honorable and that's what
was sad first time you went away how did
it happen
first time you went away so what
happened is as i make that deal with the
oblivion and i just okay we're gonna do
it so
i'm going
to colombia to show the airstrip to the
pilots
and as i'm going i made so we showed you
this trip and i called uh sal who was in
bolivia at that time and he told me they
screwed you and i'm like they screwed me
and he's like yeah all they have here is
the cocaine you bought
i had sent a million 300 000 i had about
30 130 kilos so
anyway i got on the airplane because i'm
gonna go straighten it out and i'm just
22 years old
i'm gonna go tell the generals that
overthrow government that you can't
screw me
that's how crazy you become right that's
how power goes to your head and you
think you're invincible that's why
everybody gets caught
so
uh i go down there and they apologize
and that look we had a show we had a
problem but
after this low when you send the plane
the next time we'll give it all to you
on credit
perfect i had a meeting with somos i had
to get to because i had arranged to
bring refrigerated containers full of
cocaine with diplomatic seals on them
and i had to make the meeting now this
is 1979 this is uh march april 79 the
beginning no march and there's no
airplanes from bolivia to nicaragua like
now you know maybe once every three
weeks or two weeks something like that
so i'm going to get on the airplane
because i mean nothing has happened to
us right i'm god i mean nothing what can
happen to me nothing's ever happened to
me so
we get to colombia we land in colombia
my godfather has a heart attack when he
sees me in the airplane
i mean he's the guy that handles all
operations in the united states inside
the freaking airplane you know with
not only with drugs but it could blow up
it could do anything anyway
i assure him that nothing can happen
i we refuel in the morning we head out
to nicaragua half halfway one alternator
goes off
so when one of them goes off we have
bladders inside the airplane right to
give us the distance
uh i'm like hey keep going because what
we're gonna do is return to the jungles
i mean what the heck how are we gonna
get a piece there
literally we know that the second 15 20
minutes later the second alternator will
blow and now we have we're over panama
and we had no way to get the fuel out
and at 3 000 feet that airplane just
went down
if you see the pictures of the airplanes
like that
and
when i we jump off the first door you
thought we're dead now we're live we
jump i mean because we got 200 gallons
of gas of diesel inside this airplane
and we got cocaine we got all this stuff
and uh the head of the pilot said to me
take the flare gun blow it up
i'm like are you out of your mind
that's seven million dollars in there
and it's like it doesn't matter
you're really evident i'm like listen
in latin america i buy everybody well i
made the mistake of not telling the guy
that when the military came actually i
mean i had a briefcase i always kept two
hundred thousand dollars in a hidden
compartment underneath those stamps old
samsonite shell yep so
i should just say hey here's 20 thousand
dollars make sure nobody touches that
everything but i give them my passport
and everybody's passport so they could
stamp it thinking he was stamping
locally little did i know he had to call
panama and when he did and explain what
happened next morning d.a were there
were arrested attorney general comes
to see me
and before he opens his mouth i said
look
i only have two questions i don't want
to give you some story or not
like that how much to buy the cocaine
how much to get out
and he's like noriega just sold the
cocaine 250 thousand dollars for you to
get out
i'm like
here's a number and we have a
contingency plan here's a number call
give this num this just say this exactly
this way the next day you have the money
here sure enough he kind of tells us
okay you're leaving tomorrow they're
going to take you down to a panama city
we were in the border with costa rica so
my plan was originally we're going to
upload this i'm calling costa rica i
just paid the president a million
dollars
it's easy to cross over to costa rica so
i can get another airplane to take it to
the u.s
so
they uh
they said they're going to rough you up
a little bit make it look good for the
dea
so they take us and they have this big
conference room
and literally four chairs on the back
nothing else
and they bring this little kid
patrick he could have been
100 pounds silk and wet maybe 5'4
handcuffed to his feet and his hands
they slammed them on the floor and then
they took a broomstick and they inserted
that thing up his anus
and then blood just splattered all over
the place
and when that happened the two pilots
who i had told made the mistake to tell
them hey relax take it easy i already
bribed just turning yellow not only do
they tell the d.a hey he is the biggest
drug dealer in the world this time
he just brought you attorney general so
the only guy that can get me out now is
running for his life they take us and
they put us in a dungeon for 20 some odd
days and they torture us day and night
i pissed blood for five years thereafter
every time i went to a bathroom
and you know
it's funny i tell people
the interesting thing about it is
physical pain
and i tell this to parents too listen
don't beat your kids kids all the time
the time you beat them beat them one
time and make it memorable
but pain goes away
and uh
and it does but what starts playing on
you is your mind we're in a dungeon
literally condemned they wrote a book
about it called modelo and were
handcuffed day and night no food no
water no bed a thraw against the wall so
they were like cells like this and they
would just take a fire hose and they
would just uh shoot water and clean all
that throughout well you imagine all
that excrement all the way luckily after
the second third day we had nothing to
eat so we had none to poop so we're in
good shape
but uh yeah it's your mind and i see
this guy across from me
and we made up our mind that there's no
way we're going to talk we're going to
die here and that's just there's just no
way to live with the shame that you're a
rat and there's this guy across from me
been there about six months per pot and
he was licking the bars and i kept
telling him uh my partner that was there
i'm like you know what we gotta do
something man but
i can't lose my mind in this freaking
place and and it's getting to that point
we gotta make him kill us
and and we draw the plan we're to we're
going to thread noriega he's going to
come and he's going to kill us because
that's nothing over there
and uh and we're done
so i did i told the last time they said
before you come in here because they
would come in and just beat us till we
passed out i mean they took electricity
to our testicles you jumped that high
pass out
and uh i said before you come in here
let me tell you this don't noria got to
kill us because if he doesn't and we get
out i'm going to get his wife his kids
we're going to rape him in front of him
and then we're going to kill him all
right
yeah i never killed anybody in my life
but i'm sure that definitely was going
to do it you know the bastard comes in
there laughing the next day
i mean like like it was a joke well it
was probably a joke to him you know
but uh he's like hey don't get mad at me
i didn't rat you out
and second of all you paid the wrong guy
well that was the clue that he wanted
money i said well how much he said 250
and i'm saying to myself man they only
have one going rate in this country 250.
i paid 250 for four we're only two now
man i mean you know give me a little
discount
same thing we hearing the same story the
same deal
the next day
he comes and he's like two days later he
said
get ready they're gonna get you ready
and
we're gonna take you to the airport
we're gonna take you to the airport they
put us up in this room and they took a
fire hose to clean us up we have blood
all over we look like
like
hell and and we're going and we get some
tickets we had tickets to costa rica
and uh we're sitting at the airport
they left took a left all of a sudden 20
interpol agents come
george valdez said i don't know i said
what we do they gotta threw us inside an
airplane to miami
got to miami and i was charged with
hitting the largest drug conspiracy in
the history of america in 1979
april something i had just turned 23
years old
the government asked for a seven million
dollar bail now in 1979 a murderer
he needs murder he was fifty thousand
i'm like
seven million dollars
they had the decency to reduce it to two
million dollars
i'm like i don't have a traffic ticket
i'm a college graduate
i have nothing in my record little did i
know that my attorney was writing me out
and that's how they knew and that's how
they went after us and one of those
judges he was driving he got busted and
then he traded
for me
so i hired the best attorneys in the
country and i mean and i had i had the
greatest chance to win the trial because
there was no evidence against me no
reggae i saw the cocaine i'm arrested in
panama
there's no wiretap till this day
till this day there's never been a
wiretap on me there's never been a
compromising picture with anybody on me
that's according to united states
government
till tuesday
so what happens is
i hired the best lawyers in the country
and on defense i even hired a guy that
was a state judge that became a federal
judge whose building brother-in-law was
an appellate court judge
i hired
marty weinberg out of boston million
dollars hundred thousand to tell me
whether he would take my trial or not i
hired alan dershowitz i hired uh shelby
heisman hired them all anybody else
anybody would hire a million dollar
1979.
and uh
our final argument
was real simple
this was my attorney's final argument
because they tried to indict me
in the southern district of florida no
indictment went to a grand middle
district northern diamond northern
district northern diamond making georgia
which i've never been in my life in
georgia out of all the places never been
in my life the guy that was with me had
a case spending
from three years earlier when he faked
his death i mean the guy shows up in the
courtroom and uh judge says oh mr
rosenthal welcome back from the dead say
your honor i'm only the second jew to
come back from the dead
that guy was a riot the guy was
unbelievable guy i mean big ties to the
mob anyway
aaron rosenthal
they take me to the middle district of
georgia and said i was partnered with a
guy which i had only met him a month
earlier
so our final argument is
my client is a drug dealer my client is
the biggest drug dealer in america that
was my final argument but my client has
a constitutional right of venue
he said you cannot just take him
and try him but he's never committed an
offense
try them in miami
or travel in colombia you know like some
time in colombia
didn't matter and i mean we spent
another half a million on the appeal
and uh
ended up losing so i went to jail for
five years they gave me 15 years which
is the most they can give you on a
conspiracy charge at that time
i went back to prison and i had a blast
in prison man you had a blast i walked
in there they had a big old cake for me
welcome home boss and i'm like hey dude
don't
thank you for the cake but don't welcome
me home this at home to me yeah i
mean i knew a lot of the people there
and you know i bribed everybody so i i
mean i had a girlfriend in there
a legitimate girlfriend because you know
prisoners do have a lot of girlfriends
that are they call them girlfriend but
they're like boyfriends no i had a
legitimate goal yeah so
you know and i got out and i didn't have
to do anything
when i handed off the cartel to those
guys because when i saw they were taking
me to georgia when you got out at that
time do you still have money oh i was a
millionaire they couldn't find a dollar
okay not one dollar as a matter of fact
uh justice burger
because i was given certiori on my bond
hearing which you know
the supreme court doesn't hear
and in it
just as burger says
in this gorgeous opinion mr valdez is a
financial genius
he's got assets all over the world we
can't find
and he can move and leave
in a snap of a finger i wasn't going to
go anywhere because i was going to spend
the rest of my life in on the run plus i
knew
convinced all my million-dollar lawyers
convinced me that i was going to win
there was no way i could lose
and uh
so i got out and i had a big uh we were
one of the largest cattle breeders in
the country at that time i had a big
quarter horse operation
and i didn't need to do that anymore
i had this gorgeous ranch made me half a
million dollars a year legitimate i had
millions of dollars still stashed away
and uh but i go see
sal and willie so when i handed the
cartel to them
this was they're like we'll give you
half of all the profits i said no no no
don't do that because a year into the
meeting in jail you're going to say
you know what george is in jail having a
good time and here we are risking our
life we're going to give a i said
so let's do this better
here's the money to buy 10 kilos
every load you bring in through the
operation i'm giving you i'm giving you
everything who's going to give it
how to bring it in who to sell it to the
whole bankers everything
buy me 10 kilos
sell them and send me the
that's all
oh we got to do more than i said no
don't do more just do that
well when i went to see them
they said they had
didn't have no money that they had quit
get to my second trial
and here's what's interesting that it
doesn't really come out
very clear in uh in netflix but
so
when i
i work out well let me get that and then
i'll come back so that it'll make
sequence so you know what i looked at
him and looking back it was the greatest
favor anybody ever did me according to
people they owe me like 20 million
dollars they give me a dollar but i
started my operation like that again no
problem and i started bringing in and
we're bringing in 800 a thousand one on
my birthday one month i brought in three
airplanes one after the other so you you
go in you do five times you come out
you're going back to the life going back
not even flinching and you know you're
going to get back into the life but the
different thing is yeah because it was
almost like an eagle thing
you know you got you guys like
this ain't right you know i should have
gone to jail this case i was guilty but
not what you charged me off
and uh even though recently
i did a youtube interview with the first
undercover agent in my case
ever you interviewed him yeah and in it
you can hear it he talks about i said we
never even knew there was a drug problem
in america until we found out about you
but then he says he said you know i
never forget
you walked by me
shook my hand and said congratulations
and i said yeah because here's the deal
you didn't frame me
you're not my enemy
you're my adversary
your job to catch me my not to get
caught you did a better job so good luck
see you again and that was my whole
mindset and that's why i don't have any
enemies in the government anywhere
so lo and behold
i go back to the same thing but then
this is when the world now has changed
this is when you got to carry a gun this
is when you gotta go around with
bodyguards with machine guns this is
when people are ripping people off this
is when pablo now is is in what is this
380. 84. okay 84. and uh and then now my
parents know see my mother was the best
at tough love and this is the tough love
i tell parents my mother is like son
what you're doing doesn't please god if
you go back to yours you're going to
kill us
this is not what we risked the whole
life for and then she was like what do
you want to eat tonight
you know she drew the line quickly they
lived and died in the same house
that they bought when i came from they
came from cuba
i was mad at my dad i said dad i got a
horse living in million dollar mansions
and here you all living in a 60 little
house in miami little ranch house
son your lifestyle never change ours
and uh you know just tremendous
tremendous people but my mother now
constantly saying what you're doing
doesn't please god
so what you're doing and i was like mad
at her i'm like
there's no god what god
what was god
when you know
when we came from cuba and we were
sleeping in the floor going hungry three
little kids every day god is who i make
him up to be
so
you know but she never wavered and then
it just started eating me alive and i
started to realize this ain't the world
that i signed into this ain't me
you know i'm not becoming someone that i
am and i had a friend of mine and at
this time i had the largest quarter
horse operation in the country right i
went out and bought the best horse in
the world uh in texas uh i paid a
million dollars for him ended up being
worth six and a half million dollar and
i was breeding them three thousand three
150 minutes at 3 000 plus i built a
hospital in my farm you know i was
making 900 000 plus selling my babies
anyway i had a friend patrick that would
come over and he was one of the old time
pot smugglers
and he i quit
and i would always ask him hey lazaro
how'd you quit man
because he had moved to ocala and left
the business and he's like man george
you know best thing i can tell you is
like being pregnant
quitting and pregnant say yeah man
you're either pregnant or you're not so
you either quit or you don't
and if you do you got to move out of
miami
he says why are you doing this look how
much money you got why are you risking
your life
and eventually thing one thing led to
another and i quit
i walked away in 1987 february of 87 i
was making a million dollars a month now
since the day i came out of prison until
the day i quit i never even saw cocaine
anymore i had other people handle
everything and uh and i was making over
a million dollars
after 87
for doing nothing literally for saying
send a plane don't send a plane
and where are you living at that time
are you in i live in miami yeah
and i had my ranch in closet which was
90 miles macon never inspired you to get
a house there or making george no okay
that judge was later on he became a fair
guy but the judge was like for their
trial he sends the jury away looks like
he says young man how dare tell you you
tell this court that you're innocent you
got a million dollar with the lawyers at
your table any young men can't afford
that then called the jurors i mean the
guy was brutal
uh
wilbur owens i'm not very good with the
old names but i remember that one
clearly i'm sure yeah so so it's 87
you're making a million a month all
you're doing is sending the planes
you're living in miami still living
large or are you more like a living real
party in hardcore
but i didn't party in miami
see i never did that very very seldom i
would party in california
i never you know you're saying you don't
poop where you eat yeah you know you
stay lucky like for example
how they got me how they found out about
me
uh
to do the netflix so
the producers were constantly
wondering like there's a missing link
and they've been doing this for 12 years
here we got sound willie
they're high school dropouts
they're not very smart
they're selling grams and ounces out of
disco and in six months they become
kings of cocaine
what happened
until the prosecutor that that you saw
on
uh on netflix he's like oh you have a
missing link go find george valdez
and they're like who's george valdez we
never heard of him and he's like exactly
neither had we until his attorney turned
on them
he ran this like a business i was on my
i when they seized my ranch they took
over a hundred bryoning suits
i wore a suit three different suits a
day every day i was at my office at 6 30
in the morning
i left my office at six o'clock in the
afternoon and i ran that like a business
and i didn't have shady people at me my
office we had systems and uh and that's
the whole thing and when i realized that
this is not just another business we're
doing
you know this is something now that
killing kids
and that's what really was getting to me
because now crack was coming on on the
forefront you know and uh
and i'm like so they so when they asked
me how come it was so easy for you to
walk away
when pablo chapo sal willie they had as
much money as you or more same amount of
passports or more more airplanes than
you did and they couldn't walk away and
i did i said well for me it was simple
because i never considered myself a drug
lord to me i was a businessman and this
was a product i was selling and when
that product was no longer attractive
for me to sell i walk away
they can't walk away
because that's all they are
you see both players you see athletes
when do they go down
literally in shame when they could have
gone down left the game at the top as
heroes nobody remembers the hero they
remember hey you know joe montana you
you left the game when you were sitting
in the bench
not when you were winning super bowl
because
all these people back they can't leave
that world because that's their identity
see you take
chapel
what the hell is he doing even an
interview to sean penn
this guy can go to lebanon or go
anywhere in the world the guy is doing a
billion dollars a month
a billion dollars a month
why oh i mean a week
tons of airplane power he had
distribution in every country of the
world
every continent of the world he could go
out and they'll never find them
but they can't because that's their
identity they have to be there you know
i call it uh the uh
the anguish of victory and the thrill of
defeat you know what they say that x
amount of most bank robbers get caught
at the robbery site within the first
hour they have to go back and that's
what well that was it for me so for me
it was easy i just go back to my ranch
and i just breed horses so what do you
mean in 1990 when they took 60 million
so i'm retired for four and a half years
just living the normal life
breeding horses i had a house uh in vail
i had a gorgeous condo and veil i had a
house for my beach in the ocean had jets
and i'm living this
racing my horses i'm building orange
groves you know i'm making over two
million legitimate a year
in my ranch and uh i'm at a horse show
in 1990 and they come and arrest me and
i had no clue i've been going for four
years
i'm in the middle of the horse show
and i'm like i'm clueless
what are you trusting me for
he said you'll know when you're in front
of the judge
and uh so i go in front of the judge and
he's like you're wanting to make enjoy
in uh moby alabama another place i've
ever been to in my life
united states attorney jeff sessions
once you wow
so
the the gift from god for me
was that it was a time when there was
tremendous emphasis
by the government on u.s attorney's
office
to for to have seizures
to just take you know when they see
why they couldn't take nothing from us
before because the government had to
prove that i made it illegally they
couldn't until one small ad decided hey
we'll change that
now we'll take it and let him prove that
he made it legitimate so they switch the
the proof
you know and therefore they couldn't so
when i get to mobile alabama my
attorney's meeting meets me there and
he's like you're gonna walk
there's they got one pilot to say
that
when you were in miami you were you
picked up this guy named dickie lynn
dickie lynn was a kid that was in prison
with me in eglin and was when i got out
we hooked up and he was the guy in
charge of all my transportation but we
quit he kept going and i went my way and
tremendous guy super stand-up guy he
gets indicted 150 people they'll get
convicted he gets life he doesn't ride
nobody out and there's one pilot says
hey i picked up i took the killing to
miami george valdez picks him up
dickie lynn uh
leaves with george six seven o'clock he
comes with somebody else with three
million dollars hey look what george
gave me now anyone know that that's not
how you but here's it what's interesting
the night before i got to moby alabama
that pilot
killed himself
while he was a government witness he was
smuggling cocaine on the dea airplane
and crashed in the fog in alabama
you see those planes in american made
you know where they come into the oil
field that was a lot of airplanes
so
my attorney says
you got no
you walk
and i'm like three months earlier so i
for four years
july 1st of 1990
it was my final divorce
and my ex-wife takes off with my
daughter which was the love of my life
and she's crying
when i walked away from the hotel i
hired a guy to teach me karate because
i'd done karate for a lot of years when
i was young so i couldn't go out now i
didn't have tons of bodyguards so
and uh
and the first day he says to me i'm
going to teach you about the sword
and i'm so excited man you know i love
weapons we're going to get into uh doing
the uh weapons we're not going to worry
about just throwing a punch and all that
he turns around with the bible now i'm a
die-hard atheist
i looked up and said dude
i'm paying a lot of money teach me
karate i don't believe in the book i
don't believe in what that book says so
tomorrow you leave that sword home and
bring the real sword
you have this close to me first guy many
many years
and uh and i'm like he said young man
what i got to give you you got no money
to pay
and i'm like
man i don't have a gun or a bodyguard he
got seven degree black belt is he gonna
start whooping jesus into me and i'm
gonna pay for it oh hell no
i'm like dude don't get excited no don't
get excited this is what we'll do when
the steam room is heating up after the
two hours of karate waste your time
you know tell me whatever you want right
and he did and and people say well
what'd he say that made you change i
said i remember anything i was just
getting over the two hours of butter
whooping because i didn't believe any of
it so i didn't i pay attention to anyone
but it was this
i began to see a guy patrick that lived
in a very little world right he lived in
a little thousand square foot house he
drove an old car
and what was most intriguing for me was
when he told me that he was madly in
love with his 45 year old wife
and i'm like oh no this guy's got to be
on some japanese drugs man ain't no way
45 i'm surrounded by super model i hate
them all how the hell is this guy gonna
love that old woman you know now i think
she's a gorgeous woman but that was my
mindset
and it was intriguing and i did
everything i could
to chase him away you know and uh
so what ends up happening so this is
over three and a half years so the only
thing that he would say to me which was
really really
upsetting or
i'm like come on tim why are you so
happy man you got nothing to be happy
about
he had a miserable car you know
miserable house
and we got to be good friends really
great guys and he's like ah man george
i have an intimate relationship with
jesus
and i'm like oh no
i mean i'm surrounded by people and i
have no relationship with anyone this
guy a relationship with a ghost is he
crazy
and that was my whole mindset forever
and uh
so
july 1st
july 1st 1990 11 o'clock in the morning
my wife is taking off with my baby
and uh and i'm devastated my world just
crumbled
and uh
i go into my room i get on my knees and
i'm like look god i don't believe you
exist
number one i'm gonna do if you do you're
probably enjoying you're so bad just
stay down there i'll stay up here
but if you're the reason for his joy
give it to me or kill me
because i can't buy it
and i can buy anything
and uh and and nothing happened i just
you know people say that when you have a
conversion there's belts and hiding here
must be enough for cubans you know so
i'm gonna find out what happened to the
cuban bells
but uh
three months later my world went from
dark
to complete darkness i get arrested and
i remember walking into jeff sessions
office
and i told my attorney he's right you're
gonna walk i said alan i'm done man i
can't fight these people anymore
i'm miserable and and i joke with him i
said look and by the way and this i said
it as a joke complete joke said i said
by the way here you are a good jew
telling me i'm going home i give my life
to another jewel he didn't say nothing
and he like man you're crazy you're a
mess i said i just can't fight these
people anymore what didn't want
he said well let's go so we go in there
and they say look it's real simple
lots of money
little time little money lots of time
now what can they get me for
if they can't convict me right because
there's no witness
then the other thing they can give me is
for the violation of my parole that i'm
voluntarily going to plead to
in exchange for
so my deal is so what do they do they're
like we're going to charge you with
three life sentences
three say yeah you quit or dicky lyndon
and continue criminal enterprise you as
liable for the crime you committed as
the crime he commits
and now the law has changed and it's
like no more 15 years a life sentence so
all they wanted was the money so i said
do you know how much money i got and
they're like ah no but we know who does
so they get out of the desk they go open
the door and then came three agents dea
fbi and irs
and they knew to the penny get out of
here how much toilet paper get out of
here they've been following me for four
years but wait a minute they knew
exactly how much you had exactly now
think about it the first time i go to
jail i'm a drug dealer right so they
can't find nothing
should i create a lot of
operation but now i've been legitimate
for four years i've made everything
legitimate i'm living a legitimate life
what portion of the 60 million you have
is legitimate all of it every bit of it
got it i mean properties planes uh
houses horses
jewelry
they stole about a million dollars of
jewelry that they didn't declare
i even filed a complaint on them one
agent
with customs but
so
they won it all
now
at that time
that amount of money in mobile alabama
was a lot of money
in miami not as much la not as much
but it was and uh so
our agreement our plea with the
government was
we voluntarily forfeited
then we want to plead to a
10-year sentence the violation the time
i had left in parole right i was given
15 years i served five i had 10 years
left and i already done four so my years
of that five
of that then so that's what they ended
up giving me the ten years
and then in prison i started uh ten
years and you're sixty they took all the
six everything
and this is how it dawned this is when
it really dawned on me
i go back to the cell
right and i'm in i'm in a daze
and i hear this guy say milky way milky
way
and i looked at him and said man what
the hell is this creamy milky way about
he said oh you better buy him now he
said they only give it to you once every
two months county jail moby alabama he
says the food here is bad that's how we
supplement our food i said how much i
said a dollar
man patrick is like a just a building
fell on me and said
an hour ago i'm more 60 million i don't
have a dollar to buy a freaking candy
bar
what a mental shift you got to go
through
then my wife disappears with my kids
the love of your life your daughter
for two years i couldn't find him and
then
my dad who is my best friend my idol is
diagnosed with cancer and so he's got
years to live and i don't know if i ever
gonna be released ever again
and i'm going to prison
uh
for another five years
and it's all about mindset
inmate will tell you
sleep 12 hours you sleep halfway
sentence away
i say if i sleep 12 hours i waste half
of my life
i said i might not get out of here and i
might
but whatever the case is every day i'm
going to be better
than when i wake up the other day when i
go to bed i'm going to be better than
when i woke up and i began to read and i
began to read the bible as a historical
book i still don't believe any of it and
then and then i i decided well i'm going
to get another degree so i got a
bachelor's
i said well let me start doing my
master's i started doing my master's
from wheaton college you know in jail in
jail i told myself greek because i had
no one to show me how to parts so all i
could do memorize the book so when i got
out i went so i did five years got out
went back to wheaton college and i was
on full scholarship again and living off
student loans i had no money uh i lived
it my dad helped me buy this little
eight uh 700 square foot three bedroom
house
and uh because the rent the rent taxes
were 675 bucks a month was less than the
college dorm
and uh living by yourself you're by
yourself living by myself
and and my mindset now is i'm going to
finish my master's and i'm going to do a
phd and i'm going to become the best
professor in the world and i don't have
just a bunch of pretty girls begged me
for an a what a life you know
well not really but
so when i finish my phd i'm one of five
hispanics in the country with a phd in
spanish compared to five thousand angles
i'm named the hispanic doctoral student
in america twice by the pew foundation
and
all of a sudden i meet and then there i
meet
the love of my wife life
unfortunately said to be from colombia
but you know where i thought i would
never ever in a million years right
would meet anyone but you know i met my
wife and uh and it was just uh amazing
and you know and the interesting thing
was that i have been celibate now for
seven years
and i'm like you know
is this going to work out
we've been married now for 24 years good
for you man and been together for 20 26.
you said first two marriages three years
this is first number three year now 24
next year next july will celebrate 25
and we have two amazing children and i
wake up every day of my life you know in
love and i tell you it's just the
mindset with which you look at the world
what do you do now what business are you
so right now i'm retired how did you
make your money last 24 years so when i
so i fit in my phd i'm going to teach
and then my father dies and my father
like i thought he was my hero and also
i'm in the shower and i'm pounding the
shower and i'm like man he never gave me
anything and i'm dying missing him and
then he dawned on me yeah he did he gave
you his presence
values and then oh yeah and then
i have four kids i'm like how they're
gonna remember me someone that sends a
check every month and has a good summer
we're moving
and we're going to move to georgia so i
can be a full-time dad to my kids
we're in georgia in in peachtree city
georgia so there's no university to
teach they know what to do so i started
a service master a little franchise
clean toilets cleaning taking water out
of people's house cleaning fire and it
grew and it grew and grew and when i
built it into a malt and then oh i had
my concept with government
we were involved in the cleanup of the
pentagon then at 56
i have no dad
living a very lavish life and i tell my
wife i said look at our kids
our kids we both grew up poor
our kids have been brought up with great
values to kids but they think that
normal is living a multi-million dollar
home flying around the country in a jet
again
uh vacationing in a house in mexico on a
yacht said we're moving and i'm quitting
the company i said because if a man can
define when enough is enough only grief
would drive you and he redrives you i
can tell you you're never going to be
happy and and that's how it was i know
what it is to live making a million a
month i know what it is not to have a
dollar a month it doesn't buy you
happiness and joy you know happiness
when you get up every day your life and
you say you know what
my
thing that i use phrase that i use every
time i speak at the end when the pages
of history are written will history ever
remember your name
and i'm convinced that the only way
history remembers our name is when we
have an impact in another human being's
life
so i quit and we moved to mexico i
started doing ironman
and then uh my wife wanted our kids to
go to high school in the u.s so we
stayed in mexico five years taught my
culture i took them to a place where
they could see people that miss meals
every day and still love god cozumel
okay and uh we went for a year stay five
i would stay forever to be honest with
you but she insisted we come back and we
came and uh all my kids are super
successful now you know uh my son i have
a son who at the age of 16 overdosed and
his mother called me say he's dead he's
dead 16 years old 15 as a matter of fact
christmas day
had the rescue been two minutes later he
would have died today this kid
some it's a millionaire
making
many figures a year living in malta 32
years old a cfo of a tech company
and my lawyer who uh daughter who's a
lawyer in washington for the
education department another one masters
and you know i did the same thing my dad
did i invested in my kids life and had a
vision
a vision for their life
and now i spend the rest of my life uh
we created a foundation when we built
our company we gave 10
to god
and to our foundation to make a
different people's lives and we built
churches inside prison and my mission
now is to send a million books to
prisons we send 65 000 books
and be asking why why that i said
because you know that's the whole
population that the world has forgotten
that the world has just abandoned they
have nobody left and if they can read a
book
that can tell them we are not defined by
our past
there is hope there is faith we where
there is a god that forgives
you can you'll pay the consequences of
our choices but you can be different you
can change your life then the world will
be a lot better and uh you know they say
uh
the question about how do you judge a
great parent
they say by their grandkids
your parents were great parents because
your kids are doing what they're doing
lawyer all that stuff that just means
the values your parents passed down to
you was passed down to the kids now your
kids are going to pass it down to their
kids what a story what a great story you
got there you know and hopefully this
story inspires people to not even want
to go into that life i've interviewed a
lot of different people from your world
not specifically you know
uh uh maybe
cuban uh colombian
uh cocaine although i have had some
people like that as well
and sometimes kids look at it thinking
about the lavish side but
the the trend i see with you is
you had a way of running businesses
you had a way of driving selling
tracking whatever it is accountability
building a team recruiting
that could work in illegal businesses
but could also work in legitimate
businesses and the moment you made that
transition into legitimate you won in
both places yeah use the same principles
transferable to any industry to any
industry it's the same principle that
you use you know you how do you treat
people integrity truth matters well i've
really enjoyed this i've really enjoyed
this i appreciate you coming out really
really good having you know thank you
it's been great my pleasure great so did
you enjoy it from the cocaine cowboys
the whole netflix documentary give it a
thumbs up if you did and if you enjoyed
this interview we got two other
interviews for you one of them is with
uh ed calderon from uh mexican cartel
when he was dealing with that and the
other one is with d.a agent steve murphy
and javier pena from the netflix special
narcos click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]